d'abord un mot donc ce ce ce restaurant
numéro 3 vous avez vous êtes étoilé au
Michelin depuis une vingtaine d'années
hein c'est ça ça fera 20 ans le 13
février 2024 alors j'ai lu une chose
peut-être que peut-être que que
j'aiferai on va en parler aussi avec
vous dans dans vos dans vos les menus
que vous proposez hein chez vous vous
dites voilà il y a un changement dans la
façon de de de faire de la cuisine
aujourd'hui pendant longtemps bah les
légumes ont accompagné la viande et le
poisson et on entre dans une nouvelle
ère si je peux dire où c'est le légume
qui va être le plus important et le
poisson la viande vaut plutôt être des
accompagnements ouais tout à fait parce
que on parle beaucoup en ce moment de de
de de manger moins manger mieux
évidemment mais mais en même temps c'est
c'est toute logique quoi c'est-à-dire le
légume le végétal ben il doit être nous
ça fait partie de notre alimentation
depuis tout petit donc et aujourd'hui on
le voit de plus en plus dans tout style
de restaurant oui que que tout est
transformé qu'il y a vraiment tout est
inversé quoi entre la protéine animale
et et les légumes et et d'ailleurs quand
on vous regarde vos alors il y a un menu
végétarien mais il y a un menu avec la
viande et du poisson et c'est vrai que
vous commencez par la description des
des légumes avant ouais toujours parce
que c'est c'est notre façon de faire
aussi à nous c'est notre alimentation
donc mais mais surtout sans oublier de
que la protéine animale est importante
et j'insiste toujours voilà c'est que
oui on a une cuisine qui qui est très
végétale mais la protéine animale est
très importante Jef voilà ça ça vous
gêne pas vous aucun problème j'adore les
légumes et j'adore la viande oui et pui
vous produisez aussi des des légumes et
alors il y a une autre spécificité dans
dans votre
restaurant c'est bah que vous vous
privilégiez les les produits locaux si
je peux dire enfin ouou départementaux
en tout cas ouais tout à fait on est on
est très yeline très 78 on est à 90 %
avec des des producteurs des éleveurs
mais toute entreprise des Yvelines voilà
j'insiste surtout c'est entreprise
ibllin euh et c'est c'est une évidence
il y a 20 ans quand on est arrivait il y
avait pas autant de de de produits et là
aujourd'hui on a une multitude de
produits ça s'est multiplié par par ça
en TER on en a un petit aperçu ici
d'ailleurs moi je voilà le fois gras je
pensais que c'était dans le Sud-Ouest
donc on va voir c'est aussi dans les
ivelines vous disz je crois qu'il y a il
y a qu'un produit qui est pas purement
ininois c'est le beurre il nous manque
du beurre tout à fait ouais il y a la
ferme il y a de la crème il y a du lait
il y a les œufs il y a tout ce qu'on
mais pas de beurre donc il y a la ferme
de Grignon qui en fait quelque fois
comme ça deux fois par an mais on a pas
de beurre alors on a de la crème épaisse
après on peut entre guillemets s'amuser
à faire du beurre avec la crème épaisse
fermière à plus de 36 % voilà mais on
pas on a pas de producteur de c'est
bizarre parce que c'est pas très
compliqué si de faire du beurre ben
c'est de la technique comme tout
métierin c'est une question technique
puis après c'est une question de cût
aussi ludevic pour en parler du litre de
lait pour faire de la crème par rapport
à l' de lait pour faire du fromage il y
a une grosse différence aussi donc c'est
un système complet le beurre c'est une
partie de la matière grasse du lait donc
pour fabriquer du beurre il faut aussi
pouvoir écouler du lait écrémé ou des
fromages au lait écrémé donc c'est c'est
un système complet que font très bien
les Normands ou d'autres producteurs
dans les terroirs mais un peu moins en
île-fance un peu moins en Île de France
ouais à part tout ça à part le beurre
donc on trouve absolument tout dans les
ivelines on trouve de tout en petite
quantité mais on trouve de tout VO plus
moin VO de l'eau au vin en passant par
le poisson la viande voilà et et c'est
de là euh que vous avez dit l'idée de
créer le Yolin tout à fait alors vous
allez expliquer qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire Yolin y l i n ouais alors tout à
fait donc le Y pour les ivelines bien
sûr hein le E pour olympique parce que
c'est voilà le le le 24 le 26 juillet
pouront démarrer les Jeux Olympiques le
L pour le local et le i pour inclusif
parce qu'on met tout le monde dans la
boucle voilà c'est ça alors euh il faut
expliquer on y reviendra parce qu'on en
reparlera évidemment ça va se lancer
l'année prochaine donc donc on en
reparlera au mois de janvier euh mais le
Yolin au fond c'est une base que
relativement simple euh c'est la c'est
la la la pâte qu'on retrouve dans
la dans la quiche voilà c'est le Yolin
c'est une quiche sans pâte voilà c'est
une quich en pâ pour résumer mais
comment ce qui est intéressant dans
lyolin c'était d'avoir une base et après
que que que chacun puisse s'approprier
la recette Une be relativement simple
voilà œuf farine lait voilà bon c'est
poivre c'est un plat salé mais surtout
après vu le nombre de d'entreprises et
métiers de bouche dans les ivelines ben
c'est que chacun y trouve sa patte et
chacun puisse utiliser le Yolin pour
montrer son entreprise voilà voilà alors
il va y avoir un concours encore une
fois on en parlera plus précisément au
mois de janvier mais dans toutes les
villes et et les villages de des
ivelines ça fait 200 259 59 et tous les
habitants peuvent participer les 1500000
habitants des iblines vont pouvoir
participer il y aura un gagnant par
commune tout à fait voilà une l'idée
c'est de rajouter à cette patte de
quiche bah trois produits he evelinois
voilà c'est c'est vraiment le le but la
charte de du Yolin c'est qu'il y ait
toujours au minimum trois producteurs
identifiés ou entreprises identifié des
métiers de bouche avec chaque recette du
Yolin c'est ça et et alors évidemment
vous disiez il va y avoir un un gagnant
par par village par ville village et et
il y aura un livre il y aura un livre
tout fait avec qui regroupera bah tous
les
gagnants 259 7 et 259 gagnants voilà
avec le livre qui sortira un mois avant
les Jio le 26 juin VO c'est génial non
hein super vous allez participé donc
évidemment hein oui évidemment en plus
oui c'est relativement simple c'est vrai
c'est vrai que c'est la portée même des
gens qui sont pas des des cuisiniers
professionnels ou des ou des
spécialistes comme comme vous tous
ici l'important était là vraiment c'est
de rentrer dans les foyers que chacun
vraiment s'approprie le le Yolin quoi
voilà vive le Yolin on en reparlera
évidemment
jieranopération précis il y a déjà un
site
sappelleolwle-olin.fr ouiol vous le
trouvez